est ce qu'il ya un régime spécial à
adapter alors un régime spécial adapté
non il n'ya pas de régime adapté le
vraiment le mot d'ordre c'est toujours
l' équilibre alimentaire juste adapter
les quantités puisque nos dépenses
énergétiques sont plus les mêmes on a
beaucoup moins de dépenses énergétiques
on va moins se bouger du coup on va
adapter notre assiette
surtout au point de vue portion est donc
quantité c'est à dire on va diminuer de
combien peut-être des eaux des conseils
alors on va rester sur une assiette sur
la base un tiers un tiers un tiers un
tiers de légumes un tiers de féculents
un tiers de protéines animales des
protéines animales maigre c'est sûr
qu'on va éviter les pannes hurler
friture un la charcuterie on va plutôt
aller vers des protéines maigres comme
la viande blanche le poisson du ton du
maquereau que l'on trouve aussi en boîte
les légumes et bien sûr les féculents
alors c'est vrai que les féculents reste
des sucres et c'est en ça c'est ce petit
groupe alimentaire qui va falloir
minimisé par rapport à son quotidien où
on aurait plus de dépenses énergétiques
donc l'apport de riz de pâtes de
lentilles pourquoi pas mais vraiment
petites portions à chaque repas il faut
tout utilisé justement c'est une
situation où on peut utiliser nos
placards nos congélateurs notre
réfrigérateur et donc tout ce qui est
sûr je les noms cuisiné par part contre
acheter plutôt à des protéines ou des
végétaux un brut
en fait nos cuisines et les concerts
donc ce qu'on appelle les produits
appertisés que l'on retrouve dans des
bocaux ou en conserve sont à utiliser à
partir manque c'est également mon
cuisine et donc des petits pois carottes
des coeurs de palmiers des coeurs
d'artichauts des haricots verts des
haricots beurre des flageolets du des
pois chiches donc toutes ces sources la
à partir du moment où c'est acheter brut
et non cuisinés sont les bienvenus dans
au panier dans nos placards et dans nos
réfrigérateurs bien sûr de telle manière
à avoir toujours cet apport de légumes
secs ou bien sûr de végétaux et pourquoi
pas de protéines animales puisqu'on
retrouve beaucoup de poissons de bons
poissons gras comme le thon le maquereau
les sardines le hareng en conserve et si
par cette faute de confinement ou le
moral peut blesser aussi parfois ce
qu'on a droit de faire un petit écart
bien sûr bien sûr on va pas diaboliser
les aliments à risque ou les aliments ce
qu'on appelle les aliments plaisir
justement plus on est en famille mais
c'est s'autoriser s'octroyer si on peut
ici je peux dire une fois ou deux par
semaine
que ce soit un petit à un moment
apéritif ou un brunch un matin on a là
on n'a plus un peu plus de temps pour
certains le week-end